go sam
there it is
[Music]
guys welcome back to another episode
corridor digital where we talk about
making videos life
and friend's hair today on the podcast
we've got sam gorthy on guitar
we've got ren wykman on power patch kids
and we've got nick lauron on gummy bears
and wait red you also have a dog
what's your dog's name
[Music]
yeah welcome i feel like that was a very
uh
[Music]
it was a very uh marijuana induced intro
i feel like i i just realized that i'm
using
like the same thing i use for my
microphone i have my guitar plugged into
like all the time so i could have been
doing this
oh wait you can just do this for zoom
calls
in general yeah this is plugged directly
into my pc so
amazing so let's start that let's turn
that into a thing
like actually maybe we can sell that as
a service maybe
maybe you can like you can sell sam has
like
he'll say he's just a bard that was like
a 10 years of ebard
[Music]
does rockabilly uh drive through parties
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful how about that low note though
wow um well so there you have it
uh we've already come up with a great
idea
ebardsgood.com
ebards.com services
hey christian is today's episode
sponsored i don't think it is
it is not today but it will be next week
i think it's
sponsored by corridor digital yeah
the awesome subscription stream platform
guys corridor digital.com is one of the
best subscription
streaming platforms on the market more
on that later
wait wait but i thought you were only on
youtube corridor digital
turns out no we're not only on youtube
in fact if you're listening to this
podcast audio only you might be
listening to it
on such platforms as spotify
or google podcasts or
itunes or audible or audible
is does audible have podcasts no but i
was thinking the
top 10 games book oh yeah yeah that's
israel um but anyways uh hey so
we're gathered here today i thought we'd
take a little bit of time to discuss
um you know we get a lot of questions
all the time
hey guys how do you come up with ideas
what goes into your ideas what makes a
good video
um and uh i just figured you know we've
a we've got a
an ace crew here and so maybe we could
um
we could just talk about some recent
examples maybe they don't have to be
videos we've made they can be videos
you've seen and just talk about you know
what goes into them and what what makes
a good video if you have to classify it
what makes a good video from a bad video
you know
and right i think one of the first
things uh
is your connection to
the characters that's the first thing
and it's one of the
it's one of the most diverse things
about a video but
that's the first starting point right
there is you know you can have a video
about
anything can be about changing a light
bulb it can be about
getting a drone out of a tree it can be
about uh
a boss town dynamics robot but if you're
not feeling that
you know then you're just not gonna
watch it
even if it's like the weird thing is
even when it's like a viral video you
know and it's like cell phone footage
and you see that and it's like you know
some chaotic like
moment in time what you're looking at
are the people my favorite
my favorite uh videos from the protests
has been
the the buddy comedies that go on you
know you're
you see these crazy characters yeah
rogan james franco
what did you call him never mind
i i see what you're saying i think any
video
that you find good it's totally you know
objective but
any video you find good has a personal
connection and that is where
character comes in you're and you're
right it is subjective you know
oftentimes what makes a good video is is
highly subjective
but um you know like
there's still some through lines like
you you might not know a good video when
you see it but you certainly
know a bad video when you see it and
and the first thing about that you
notice with a bad video is like
oh i'm not i'm i'm just totally checked
out
30 seconds in you're not even you're not
even
it feels like two minutes it feels like
an hour
because you haven't actually taken the
time as the creator to present
the first and foremost human personality
yeah i mean i think there's a recent
example we dealt with uh
jake and sam and maybe ren also in our
editor applications uh yeah you know
there were hundreds
thousands yeah that's it yeah uh
because because i'm you know you were
talking about that and i was thinking
like
when do i watch bad videos like because
usually
bad videos you don't watch right right
like
you realize usually subconsciously this
is a bad video i don't want to be here
i gotta go watch a good video and
luckily youtube also does a good job
with the algorithm but
yeah that that uh that exercise of
watching through i'm sure you can speak
to this
uh watching through all these editor
applications
there's some some i mean i'm not going
to dis on anyone
there's no particular one we're going to
discuss with people but i mean
there's obviously a level there's a
whole spectrum of quality
and some of them were bad and how do you
quantify that
it's easy i think the bad ones come down
to like three concepts which is
um if you're if you're going to
communicate something
to someone you need to get to the point
of what you're trying to communicate
very quickly or at least
give people a hint of hey i'm about to
give you
two more points you know that's why
that's why i said hey i've got three
points
yeah and so yeah and so that's the first
one though it's like the idea of like
getting grounded and like storytelling
any communicating anything
is important um you don't want to hear
someone ramble and then ask them wait
what are you talking about you know i
feel like
that it happens in everyday
conversations too yeah
i feel like one of the more important
things about a video is it's pacing it
has to have good pacing whether that's
fast pacing or slow pacing depends on
the content itself
because you can have a bad video that's
just cut too quickly right
we could have a bad video usually a bad
video is just because the pacing is way
too slow
so it's like you know people ask what is
the good length for a video
well the answer is 10 minutes so you can
get that extra mono inside
now it's only eight courtesy of new
youtube right yeah
but yeah um in truth a video needs to be
as long as it needs to be
which sounds like a cop-out answer but
it's the truth because a video could be
three minutes long because the content
can only support itself for three
minutes
or in the case of our recent video with
getting the drone out of the tree that
was a 22 minute video
you rarely make videos that are longer
than 20 minutes but that video kind of
like it
it it was not fast-paced but
there was no fluff that's the important
thing it's like anything that's in there
has a purpose whether it's for education
or entertainment
it has to have a purpose that's i think
i was going to combine
the second point a little bit with with
that idea of pacing but
what you said is everything has to have
purpose and i think
that that i think that's those are both
ways to
sum up the same thing i feel like pacing
is something that you it's it's very
objectively easy to see
but just the thing is is when slow paced
things work it's because they're still
giving you
purposeful relevant information at the
right time that you need to know it
and so i feel so it's it's it's a very
subjective area but ultimately
you can sum it up with saying only
include
information with purpose to your point
and if you are going to include
something that isn't purposeful to the
point
it's it's good to maybe kind of like
highlight that in a way you know like
make it yeah
make it yeah um like a satire or a
cutaway or something well i i feel like
it's it's fluff right you don't want to
have fluff in your video just for the
sake of being there but fluff is okay
if it's entertaining tactical fluff you
need some of that the drone video has
that
a little bit like those character
moments and like you know some story
elements that
aren't necessary but serve the audience
serve the character
yeah i think both the things that you
mentioned wren pacing and sam getting
to the point right out off the bat are
both things that
we're lacking in the less good
submissions that jake uh and yeah you
know we all went through for those
submissions a lot of people like would
just
not really cut to the core of what sam
wanted from like what
the scene was uh like i came by to scan
the studio and
you know it's a whole scene with a guy
coming he's a technician for leica
coming by
setting up this awesome lidar scanner
and sam wants to use it for
his unreal stuff but that's the story
this guy talked for about 20 minutes
about the the tech
and it's all really interesting stuff
but
a lot of people hung up on that stuff
and not sam's like
cutting through to what sam wanted out
of him and what sam wanted out of that
text
purpose of why he was there in the first
place and the best ones
took that guy's mission statement out of
his dialogue you know they found it in
what
um sorry sam's mission statement and any
supporting
quotes that the guy was you know
information that the tech was giving him
and put that as the intro to the video
so you gotta pay off already like right
as it started you know
you know they set up the same story and
after you set up the story in a video
then
you can justify some
fluff i think interesting because it's
all it's it's
it's kind of relative to itself in a way
like
when you talk about pacing and you talk
about like
cutting to what's important to like move
the story along
it's sure it's kind of like
you know when you when you start and you
have an idea
whether that's like in paper or in video
it's kind of like you're you're standing
at the top of a ridge line
and and you have like a ball and you can
you can only put the ball down
once but you can put it down wherever
you want
you know but then once it's down like
you start to
eliminate the possibilities that can
come from it
right as and as it gets further down the
hill there's less and less things that
it's capable of doing
uh until you get to your final
destination
but it's too late and then it's too late
you can't go back
up the hill yeah no but then your
stories run
you know yeah i'm gonna throw one more
thing out there yeah what was their
third
final um it's expectations
and it comes from expectations from
obviously you can you can apply to
character stuff but ultimately it's all
about the audience
it's all about what are the audience's
expectations going into something
and why or how are you going to betray
those expectations
yeah and and that's super important
because it works in two ways and it
works for any type of story
um it works for stories where you know
exactly what's going to happen but you
have no idea how you're going to get
there
i think ren's drone video is kind of
like a good example of that kind of
thing where it's like
look it's a drone in a tree like we know
he's gonna get it down
but it's all the things and the steps
that you go to get there
that make it interesting and those are
the unexpected elements
um and then it kind of inversely works
too
in the sense of um like
like something you know going towards a
task that seems clear-cut
and the goal seems very straightforward
from the start
but that goals the expectations and that
goal shifts into
newest results and like the story itself
can you know
spiral there i mean yeah and usually
those something like those those
goal shifting stories where the the
expectations of the goal changing
usually that ends up kind of still being
a cyclical story
like the first one which is oh we got to
the place we kind of
all kind of we didn't it's the story
where you you didn't know that you knew
the goal the whole time
you know it's and so that's like the big
difference there
yeah um so yeah i feel like that's the
best way to sum it up because there's no
reason to tell something someone
or tell someone something they already
know you know it's like ren got the
drone down from the tree it's like
all right yeah i got it down from the
tree it's like
okay yeah you know
and and like what's it what's another
great example uh like what the uh the
guy who
uh free soloed uh uh the
the in yosemite or whatever right
like you know yeah alex
it's same same thing there which is like
that movie would have been way lamer if
it was like
just a sweet i mean it would be pretty
cool but if it was just him starting at
the bottom go like here we go
and then he gets to the top it's like
the end and you're
you're like all right you did it
you know it's like it's still cool but
like
there's nothing unexpected so much
that's happening in that version
well yeah and then plus with that it's
like the context is everything you know
the whole movie is basically
setting up why this is such a crazy
monumental task
and then he goes and does it and so it's
like it's its own built-in reward
yeah yeah another thing to consider is
that like
we're kind of talking about a very
specific kind of video here we're
talking about like
narrative videos even if they are kind
of reality based like a drone recovery
video
you know stories well i feel like i'm
trying to keep this stuff general enough
where it applies to even a 30-second
thing
well i'm talking like what about like uh
so videos that jenna likes to watch are
like these half-hour chiropractic videos
where it's literally just a person
popping a
person's back
she doesn't she doesn't watch it for
education
it's well the chiropractor is kind of
entertaining uh
but like i mean yeah it's basically is
this
this professional chiropractor who uh
she gets these clients in and
she does all this stuff to this person
it's kind of crazy to watch kind of
satisfying to hear the
pops but there's like there's no story
there's no like evolution or whatever
it's just a video that exists
and it's like there's tons oh my gosh
yeah
i'm thinking about like a boston
dynamics video where she comes out with
like
kettlebells and she's like
this one's called this video is called
scary loud first time chiropractic
adjustment
oh jeez chiropractic changes life
okay so videos that many believe to be
good videos
but they don't follow the sort of story
format that we at
corridor have like cultivated for our
own videos you know but do you still
have stories you still have set up
payoff or pacing and expectations it has
everything to do with expectation you're
right it's like you know what you're
getting into when you click on an asmr
video you're gonna have like sure
this cute little girl is gonna be like
hey
yeah well yeah i feel like you could you
could liken that analogy though still to
like
all right you want a good meal let's go
to in and out and then someone's
someone else is like how about we go to
like a five or four star
restaurant and get like a steak dinner
it's like both
meals objectively taste good and are
satisfying
but it's about it's just about about
this like level of detail and craft you
want to talk about
you know i feel like you can you can
make stuff
i don't know it's true yeah on all
levels but for instance
one of my favorite videos to come out
this year is titled
building a 3.5 kilowatt hour diy solar
generator for 650 dollars start to
finish
and it is from this channel called
lithium solar and he is kind of my new
favorite youtuber
he's rarely on screen he doesn't really
have like the sort of like
youtuber presence but he's very good at
like communicating like some technical
details really efficiently
and this video is a 33 minute video and
it's got
over 2 million views and it's literally
just him going through extremely
technical detail of how to build a
battery pack
and next thing i know i finished the
whole video i was like what happened
where did my half hour go i didn't even
realize i just spent all this time
watching this
fascinating video i've since gone on to
watch almost every video on his channel
so that's
an example of like no story wait what's
this
his name is lithium solar okay that's
his youtube channel
there can't be two million people that
genuinely want to follow along in this
process so what do you think he did
right
yeah in the video to get people to watch
that 30 minutes
now are you just interested i don't i
don't see it is this is this one of the
best
battery videos you've seen
this is one of the best battery videos
i've seen it's okay so what sets that
apart from other battery videos yes
what is the magic here let's bring i'm
talking about this after i
rewatched the video because we're in a
whole new category we're not talking
about like
hey it's it's friday night 9 p.m you
want to relax you grab a beer and you
watch
like a 90-minute battery well this is
exactly what i did it was a friday
evening i had my beer
threatened me with a good time
okay never i take it all back
but uh i think it's because there's no
fluff
it's a yeah it's a half hour video but
every like
every piece of information he's
communicating is useful and also kind of
fascinating because it's
kind of bizarre like he goes through
like welding battery packs to nickel
strips
and and then kind of like doing stuff
but like as soon as he starts doing
something repetitive it cuts to the next
piece
in the puzzle it's like uh
yeah the procedure is very lengthy i
don't know how long it took him to do
this but like
it never gets repetitive but it always
constantly
feels like it gives you that your own
sort of diy
feel where this guy is a battery god
everything is
what's his channel very clear called
lithium solar he's not verified or
anything he's got 60k
subscribers
yeah i've been wanting to collab with
him or something but i have no idea
where he is
if he did anything like this but he
knows the stuff when it comes to
batteries
this is incredible well i'm scrubbing
through this video
and everything's extremely well lit it
never stays on the same shot for too
long
yeah it seems like there's constantly
new yeah
pretty interesting stuff going on
it's it's fairly interesting it's also
fairly esoteric you know it's like no
one
knows really how to do this i have put a
lot of time into figuring out how to do
this and even i'm still like i'm
learning a lot of stuff here
dude this is the same thing as permit
this is just primitive technology yeah
it is pretty modern
primitive technology okay so why is
primitive technology
let me let me let me through my pitch
here because this is like we're in a new
different we're gonna like uh
i can't tell for a new category or not
of like what
constitutes something a good video
because this is
it's very abstract at this point but let
me just say like primitive technology
this guy there's a big thing that's
happening here which is
they're building something step by step
and they are not
messing up like think think about this
like think about something you know how
to construct or build
now imagine you're gonna film yourself
doing it and
every step of the way that you film is
basically
going to be the correct move you know
imagine not messing up
and having to correct for something like
for me whenever i'm building stuff
there's errors you know and i have to
deal with it on the fly it's not like a
now i'm gonna do this click done success
now i'm gonna do that you know it's like
there's there's this perception of like
taking a complex task and then
making it basically like approachable
and like
it it empowers you with the feeling that
you yourself can accomplish this
no matter who you are because you you
are watching someone do it and it
seems apparently incredibly easy i think
there's there's something to that like
watching
someone like what jake when you first
told me the idea for this
oh it's empowering
yes but for real though it's like it's
empowering
yeah because you're like a it's
educational
it's inspirational because you're like i
understand how to do this now even if
you
maybe don't have the skill to do it you
know how it's kind of done but also
there's something to
i think in any situation watching
someone who is good at something
doing their craft or their passion right
is going to be entertaining no matter
what it is
like once it's just there's a fast
that's
there's a fascination with that that's
why prim tech i think is so cool
um that's why this battery guy is
i think that's compelling the idea of
the power empowerment because like
i'm thinking about like okay what is
this battery video and the matrix have
in common
you know i'm serious and like when
you're watching the matrix you're like
jazzed up and you're like [ __ ] yes like
dude this guy's [ __ ] got a minigun
now
and he's blasting everyone and he's
yeah the dopamine receptors are going
off and
i'm trying to figure out like how the
because i know that feeling and i
i feel like a mild version of it when i
watch content like this
where it's like my imagination is like
it feels possible to accomplish these
once tasks that were once impossible
um yeah so there's some there's
something there
i don't know and i feel like well maybe
like a good story kind of gives you the
same effect as
this in the sense of like you get
answers
and you or you get like visceral
satisfaction from both
like a matrix and a guy putting a
battery together there's also something
insanely neutral about it where it's not
political
it's not um oh i just cut out
nope um it's sorry i lost video
it's not political there's no like
personal
you know vitriol or like opinions going
on you're literally
just like with someone doing what
they're good at
and you get to just absorb that pure
purely um
i think there's something really
relaxing about that as someone who
watches a lot of these types of videos
yeah and actually kind of closer this is
closer to like watching mad max fury
road this battery channel
you know monster trucks and explosions
and you're like
wow what a cool shot like look at what
these
great people accomplished but yes
uh nick you mentioned like or one of you
mentioned like two million people have
watched this surely not two million
people are
interested in building a battery pack
and i saw the same thing when i used
to make tutorials on my channel like i
used to make a lot of after effects
tutorials
and i would always get comments uh on
each video saying man
i have no idea how to do effects but i
watched the whole video
and those comments always just kind of
like blew me away i'm like
why like why did you just watch this
20-minute tutorial
on how to use this program that you're
never gonna open
it's like primitive technology man it's
like watching someone
do what they're good at i think there is
a direct comparison though
to to these types of videos and a good
story
a good a good dramatic narrative because
in these videos you're watching somebody
and like you said sam there's
there's this one-to-one like compounding
effect where it's like
they're going through a complex process
but they're doing so step-by-step
and in any and as in anything that
humans do like
it's all just a bunch of small steps
like
put together you know and and that can
become complex but each step in and of
itself
isn't that difficult and when you're
watching a good
story a person might be
or a character might be going through
like this this giant
challenge or you know some some other
sort of like
large character arc but the satisfying
thing to watch
and the grip well and it's more gripping
than it is necessarily satisfying
is to watch them go through each stage
of that and to watch how they react and
react
again as they go through the stages even
when that's in a short video like even
when
even when it's like a two-minute video
um
you know or like like some of mark
rovers videos where he's built like
you know like when he did that glitter
bomb one or like something you know and
you're just watching people
react to this thing that you know they
don't know it's coming
and then you're getting this yeah yeah
you're getting this very like visceral
like
hey i'm glad that they i'm glad that
they reacted that way
i'm glad that they that then this
happened or like
you know or it was gripping to me to
watch this because i didn't know how
they were going to react
um and and all that it's kind
of it's weird to think about magmax fury
road in this video in the same sentence
but yeah you have to yeah
because when when uh i forget what
charlie's throne's character's name is
but
when she's going furiosa here yeah when
she's going through all that
and then you got mad max there
it's like i mean
yeah like a prim tech video almost has
all those elements in the title alone
like it sets up urgency like like
building myself
a a roof yeah yeah from scratch
urgency
i lost my train of thought but anyway i
think that those videos still have a
very boiled down
version of yeah well that's kind of
story elements that are essential
it's kind of what i was getting at when
it when i was talking about the human
thing at the beginning
is like you know the first thing you
need is a human connection
and and that's you know the the like i
built myself a roof
or like i built a generator for 650
dollars
that goes to something deeper than just
watching somebody build something you
know
it goes to like like why is it that
the solar the diy solar generator for
650 dollars
is the important one the reason why
that's the important one is because
that's the thing
that goes to like the most basic human
need it's like
i can get power from the sun
more power less 650
and with power i can do all of these
other things with my life
or i can make a roof out of mud and
sticks right in a day i feel like
with my land this we've we've
entered a new territory where we're just
talking about what makes
interesting information in general
[Laughter]
we need to go further one step further
what if we talk about complex story
element and
karen freak out videos well
let's spend a moment to kind of talk
about our own approach to making uh what
we consider
uh a good video for like say the crew
channel like what are the main
ingredients
that we consider a good video yeah in
terms of like what we try to make which
has like the story aspect there's like
an arc to a video there's like you know
beginning middle and end etc
um so what what would nick what would
you say the most important
uh thing in a crew video would be
uh a problem a challenge
must be like some conflict yeah stakes i
mean that's
it's all kind of within that
but you need a problem i think um
something to be solved or like personal
or
a need however yeah any story has a need
right
the character needs something they want
something yeah
but that's where all of our stuff starts
really it's like
all right um i want i have a problem i
want to make this or
this person did this i want to do this
for them or to
them you know it's like uh ren had a
problem in that your drone had been
in that tree for three months was it
yeah it was three
yeah surprise that wasn't set up he
really did have a drone up there for
that one
well it's like so many of our videos are
are very much so that way they're
they're like we approach it
we we identify a problem and we can see
the solution being something that can
potentially be entertaining
and so we just kind of like start
letting it happen
like uh yeah you know and sometimes it
kind of goes a direction that's
disappointing other times it goes a
direction that is like
amazing like we couldn't have planned
for it to be any better like the end of
the the nerf drone video how
like jan and i face off and i just
completely destroy him like that was
that could not have gone better
especially with jan being the antagonist
throughout the entire video
that's speaking of story that's one of
like me and dean were just talking the
other day that's one of our
like proudest videos of like last year
or was that this year it's all a blur i
don't know
of the last year it was like it was the
last video we did before going into
quarantine
okay yeah almost like that seriously
feels like a year ago
no anyway i digress but that video is
like the perfect i think summation of
how story can be brought into a real
life
uh series of events yeah like
this was a project you had really been
passionate about
and we had a real life villain in the
office and we just went with it
we never asked jan to say any of those
things
we didn't him to be like an antagonist
he just kind of fell into the role he
just
yeah he does janice like he's like
waluigi man
that's perfect well uh the other thing
about
like letting stories happen when we just
did the drone in the tree video
last week we didn't know how that was
gonna go
when we started we we knew that it was
up there
and we knew we had some footage of it
being kind of
like of us talking about it of you
talking about it with freddie
we knew that if you could if you could
reapproach it
on camera that there could possibly be a
story there but we didn't
we didn't know sam i don't know if you
know this but we didn't know that we
were he was going to be able to get it
down
well yeah sam it was there was a big
assumption
going into that whole project and the
assumption was i was going to get the
drone down
and there were definitely some moments
where i was like oops
i'm sure sure i mean but i mean well
maybe this is just me knowing
the people of you know knowing that you
guys were approaching it
i was like
but this is where we differ wren as
someone in front of the camera
and someone behind the camera your
assumption is that you're gonna get the
drone down my assumption is that
you're not gonna get it down until you
run into like several problems and
that's what i'm hoping for
right what else i don't have a video
like if you're something that has been
correct
right away like can you imagine i would
have been boring if we actually got it
down with the arrow
yeah like had we gotten there in the
morning we tried the arrow it gets stuck
we shake it and then the drone falls
down doesn't land in the tree blow it it
just lands at the ground like great
cool we got the drone back we don't have
a video now
but even so even so like say that would
have happened
you still could have made a story now
it's never
it's never as fun to make a story as as
if it
if it actually like plays out before
your eyes at least in the context and
what we're talking about
but you could have went back and then
like told nico that you didn't get it
and then like played some other you know
definitely
game of cards there with that
expectation we would have had a scramble
though a little bit for like yeah where
does this go
yeah because our main conflict would
have resolved but i mean
we've gotten good at you know being able
to adapt and overcome
or it falls out of a window on the
freeway on the way back
way back than you guys are also we've
gotten good at fusing together
real uh genuine moments and real um
uh struggle with more like cultivated
specific storytelling moments to support
all the real stuff
yeah yeah i mean here's my thing it's
like
i get we don't want to be 100
faking stuff right but there's a lot of
stuff going on in the studio
there's a lot of discussions that happen
when cameras aren't rolling
and if i hear someone say something that
is useful for a story
i think it's totally okay to go back and
even like
make a scene of that thing happening
once again for the story
if it means getting it on camera if it's
important yeah we do that all the time
and there's no
there's no like oh shame shame on you
like that we're
we're literally there the purpose of the
crew channel
is to tell stories and yeah usually
they're founded in some version of
reality that we're actually
experimenting with
and sometimes they're 100 like that's
just the way that it went down
but other times they're not and it's
better to like
imagine and to expand upon like
someone's imagination
to tell a better story than it is to
just like that oh well we were gonna do
that and then uh wren got the drone out
of the tree
you know it's like what an opportunity
wasted
definitely yeah and i yeah i mean the
whole point is to make it fun to watch
yeah and then go on oh yeah and but also
just like
it doesn't matter if it's not on camera
you know so if we have to make it
make it up to get it on camera like
remember okay remember
when we did the boosted board battery
mod video
like five years ago at this point was it
four or five
um the ending of that video i
i get into the studio and i was really
late because i was spending a lot of
time trying to get this
board of this studio and then like the
last like three miles i'm literally just
like
long boarding and we filmed that whole
scene
where jake's like what happened where
were you and i'm like i don't know it is
like a scramble
all of that footage disappeared yeah
all of it was gone the entire ending
resolution to this video
was wiped from the planet and what we
ended up having to do
is restage that entire thing where i
open up the door drop my
skateboard and bag on the ground and
you're like where have you been it's
like
right that was all done for a second
time what you see
in the video is a recreation that's
right
like that's just an example um i mean
and we do that all the time for other
people
yeah yeah uh should i should i reveal
the dirty little secret about the drone
uh rescue video please yes please yes
uh oh taking a look under the hood so
what do we got in here we got tuesday
morning we got up early and we went to
the park
and we managed to fly the drone into the
tree and rescue
the other drone the original drone flew
the mavic into the tree so
that drone fell out of the tree and
landed on the big gazebo bush
yeah uh then
we went to the studio and filmed the
scene with nico and i
where nico's like you have to get that
drone out of the tree
or else you got to repay the uh
studio for the gopro i'm like oh no how
are we going to do that
well here's the man we went back and
nick climbed up the tree to get it out
of the bush
that was the but i have to make this
really important
distinction here though where is yes
that was
what you would call faked but that was
only because
the actual conversation where nico had
that with you
happened months ago and wasn't filmed no
that's what i'm saying it doesn't matter
if it's not on camera
but that's the thing is that there are
yeah context was real
but what was captured and what the
audience sees
was technically um whatever fabrication
but it was still like
dramatizing all we're doing is
dramatizing the real stories that are
happening
yes and like you know when you see that
thing like on a crime show where it's
like a dramatization
or of the killer sneaking around and
it's like not the actual footage of him
sneaker
he didn't sneak around in that shot but
he did what he did
at one point he truly did sneak around
they're walking around
yeah but that's the thing and with just
what like that conversation with nico
it's like that wasn't the actual
conversation where that happened
but nico did have that it's so it's like
exactly
it's still it's still truthful at its
core but for the sake of like
making sense out of it from a story
standpoint you have to do those kind of
things
i have to put that out there because i
don't want people going through these
videos and like
oh my god this is all fake like i don't
know what to believe anymore because
yeah but that's the thing is this it's
like it it still is
just as real whether we re films of the
conversation or not
exactly there's always some sort of
basis in reality for it
it's not like we're just making stuff up
for the sake of like drama
the only time right like wes and jacob
wasn't jake really wanted to have a
trial
that's exactly what i was about to
mention the whole like
sometimes sometimes like only because we
think it's funny and it's important
to us everyone's in on the joke you know
that works because it did screw up the
camera
we're not trying to actually make people
think we're gonna [ __ ]
like take nico to prison like that's a
good
that's a good joke like
nick yeah nico had put down that rule
of like you got to keep the stuff off of
the table and we had it on camera
the whole thing the whole reason why
that video came to be was because we
were talking about like
what should we do like he broke the rule
well if it was an exploration of what if
we actually followed our own rules for
once
which we thought was funny because we
don't like that camera room
is like a tornado all the time and like
it was like well what if
we actually like followed our rules and
like we had to
pin this on nico himself you know
because so
but also that video is just a joke
really just an improv
show it was us doing it performing an
improv show where the audience was the
camera
um and you know and it was entertaining
uh i had a friend
uh talked to me was like i have no idea
why that video
was so entertaining why did i watch that
entire thing why was i enthralled the
entire time watching that video it's the
stupidest thing i've ever seen but i
couldn't look away it was so fun
i'm like thank you exactly
hey next time next time someone's got to
be gone
like for an extended period of time
we should have them go on trial for
something like prior to
prior to them being gone and then and
then
explain them being gone away as like as
if they went to jail
they went to corridor court they're gone
they got banished
yeah that would have been easier to do
back in like mid 2016 when we had a new
video
coming out every other day yeah that's
another thing
our our style of videos that we've made
have evolved so much in the last four
years
uh i mean just assuming we're starting
from the vlogs you know like obviously
we were making content for years before
that but like
you know the vlogs go where'd the vlogs
go back
they're coming back on the website yes
obviously far less structure but there's
always something that the
there's always a point to this video
there's always something that one of us
were either exploring or doing
and the camera was just along for the
ride and so a lot of these same
principles applied to those earlier
videos
yeah a lot of lessons learned in that
process honestly because
when we started that we were we were
we were primarily focused on uh
narrative storytelling and visual
storytelling and
being on camera as talent
ourselves telling our own stories about
our own challenges wasn't something that
any of us were really familiar with at
that time
and uh sometimes those are more fun to
watch
because there's like some real moments
of like
like real like situations happening and
that
like and nick and carmichael had the
audacity and like the balls to just like
get into a conversation and just like
point the camera at somebody as there's
like
some really pretty intense conversations
happening
is very uncomfortable it's like this
conversation on camera but here we are
we're excited to bring that back a
little bit on this
yeah yeah i do miss a little bit of that
and
and some of that some of that a little
bit of like live action like
you know real time here's the situation
as it's
playing out is it just i think it just
makes you better you know like it it
makes you better at like
engaging with people it makes you well
you can see if you can see us getting
better
at like conducting ourselves and like
telling stories
like if you watch like jake in the early
vlogs
you're so different dude like you're so
like awkward but like
you just didn't like know how to present
yourself and you know
i mean i'm the same way like back in
those early days uh
maybe not so much the vlog but like any
time i was on screen for like a behind
the scenes video
it always like looking back at those
video clips i'm just like this is so
cringy
why am i like this why am i the way i am
everyone's like that but i feel like
i've become more natural on camera
which is actually a bit of a skill set
to develop it's not necessarily like a
natural thing
and i've only developed that because
i've been on camera for the last
however many so years i mean yeah same
thing for all three we often we take for
granted quite a bit
um but uh so
just a little side note on that i went
back to my hometown
uh last september for this uh
like sports event thing where i had to
give a speech
and um what yeah well they were
inducting me
came the community oh just a little
induction into the little hall of fame
yeah you know best ever black at the
community
track you know not a big deal um jordan
was in the front row but you know
whatever no big deal president lebron in
the front row
um no so so i had to give a speech and
uh and it's a short speech you know but
like
everyone brought up their you know
everyone brought up their like piece of
paper
and whatever and but i like
but like the day before i was just
memorizing like my talking points
honestly
memorizing what i was and i was kind of
just like i had my
i had my outline in my head and then i
just went up there and i was just like
and it felt just like i was talking to
the camera you know there's like a light
in your face
and you can't really see you just know
that it's like there
and i just kind of did the same thing
that we do
normally when we turn the camera on and
then after
space squarespace
and then afterwards this guy was like
man like uh like uh you should be a
public speaker like you're really
natural up there and i was like
i didn't think about it but then i
realized like oh the reason why that is
is because of all these times where
we've been
you know just on camera and on camera
and on camera
um these two better stories
it also kind of leads to a bit of
awkwardness whenever you meet people in
real life like whenever i meet fans who
approach me and they're like hey
you know they have this preconceived
notion of who i am because of who they
they see in these videos which
it's like me on camera me who is in all
of these corridor
crew videos and me in real life are very
similar but they're not exactly the same
i'm i'm definitely a little bit more
heightened
yeah version of myself on camera and
you're edited i'm edited yeah
also everyone says i'm so unbutt a lot
too i i'm so bad at that i'm still so
bad at that um
yeah and like yeah and also what
being on stage is like a unique thing
though because it's like
different scariest thing but once you're
up there it's it's uh
like everything changes it's like the
audience
disappears and you're just doing your
thing yeah
every time we do those adobe
presentations at
me it's like like i go up there and it's
like it's really ner
you're really nervous and then once it
gets going
you're just like i'm just gonna like
dance like a monkey and try and make
people laugh
for the next hour and that's my only
goal
it's like you have your outline but yeah
it's like
it's easy to get comfortable once you
get that singular focus of like all
right
i'm just just doing a thing no one cares
if i get some chuckles that's all we
need yeah that's true
i mean and that's that's what that's
those little things
that's what makes a story i mean that's
how you tell
an engaging story to begin with you know
is is it's not just the information
that's being conveyed
but it's how you're conveying it um and
that's
uh there's something there's something
deeper there too than than just
like necessarily what makes a good video
but but really what
like the presentation of information in
a in
in a precise in a characterized way
in a way that is like stylized with
someone's personality
is more interesting almost
every time and you're more likely to pay
attention to it
than if it's just you know reading from
scripture or whatever
the thing i think about a lot lately is
um like the idea between
like theater or like even just telling
jokes as a comedian and person the more
i listen to like the joe rogan podcast
and here comedians talk about their
experience of
practicing bits so to speak and refining
them
really has gotten me thinking about like
well when you do
stuff in video form you're basically
like
you're citing everything in you know
you've got everything cleaned ready to
go and you're like here we go and you
take the shot
and that's you get one shot you know
what i mean
if the joke doesn't land you don't like
delete the video
make some edits and re-upload it i mean
it's it just requires such a high bar of
like precision and forethought that you
can't you can you can
you can test it out as much as you can
by like
what showing it to friends people etc
but
that reminds me nick your mom is always
going to think your video is good okay
yeah like yeah nick do you remember we
were
when we were filming the drone retrieval
video that woman
came up to the gazebo and she's like
yeah mind if i start
like practicing my material and we're
like
huh she's like my comedy material do you
mind if i just practice it here and
we're like sure yeah nope
no problem and so because we're so she's
just like
[Laughter]
we'll laugh about that later yeah yeah
she's like set on another audience
it's like a 60 year old woman wearing
scrubs who was just
like have be up on a platform and just
say her jokes
out loud it wasn't that she was like she
i think she was kind of hoping no one
would be there
but we were so she just dealt with it um
and she had a couple jokes that were
pretty funny i think most of the jokes
kind of were just like
you know like but she's practicing and
and then she
finished and left and it was like huh
okay
i'd never really come across something
like that in the wild before
yeah i don't think i don't think many
people do
yeah i was talking with with somebody
that um
was in comedy and that's kind of they
said i was like how did you get into
that
what do you what do you do
and she basically said uh
what i did was i would go to laundromats
and and i would just like do my laundry
and then while i was doing my laundry i
would just practice my jokes
out loud to people and then see if
people reacted to them
interesting and that's very smart it
works captive audience in a way
like yeah that's actually really smart
because like how else
how else would you do it because if you
practice it with friends or like family
it's
it's almost as if you know they're too
they're too close to you
yeah you get the pity laughs yeah to
give you an accurate assessment of
whether or not it's actually
[Laughter]
like high cheeks like they laugh
before you say the punchline of the joke
yeah i haven't said the funny part yet
it's
really funny maybe i should just say you
rewrite a joke so that it doesn't have a
punch line because of that and then all
of a sudden this just makes it worse
it's just man yeah yeah but yeah that's
um
we kind of do the same thing in a in a
weird way um it's just it's posted on
the internet sometimes
and you know oftentimes we'll show each
other
i mean that's a good source of way to
make a video better right there
is like oh do so do show it to your
friends
family and do show it to people do show
it to small audiences and get their
feedback
watch my two-hour battery tutorial yeah
i mean maybe not that but
we do review sessions in the studio
where it's like all right this video is
done
let's all watch it and then give notes
and sometimes that can be a bit
problematic because everyone's busy but
like
usually the videos turn out better
because well first off we've all gotten
good at being able to
um cultivate good critiques and good
feedback
um but also it's like you know just
getting outside perspectives on those
things
just little suggestions here and there
something like oh i didn't even consider
that
um and then you implement it and
suddenly the video is better
that is that is a very easy way it's
like just have just even if it is
someone close to even if it is like your
significant other or or a partner or a
friend
yeah just watch the video uh yes they're
gonna be biased yes they'll give you
like
biased reviews especially if they're
trying not to hurt your feelings but
a lot of the time they'll maybe like
they'll have a question like i didn't
understand that bit right there and
you're like huh
i it makes sense like it didn't make
sense to me because of this you're like
oh i get it now so now
you go back and you fix that moment and
the video is better yeah
yeah never uh get too attached that's
definitely
important carmichael had to post it
we've all killed your babies
there's a there's a video actually sam
um
you and i and nico are watching uh
minecraft john cena
and i don't know if you remember that
video while it was in post
but it didn't quite like hit
what i was going for you know it was
only like the third video or whatever
that i had like actually
like directed and it didn't and it
didn't quite
wasn't quite there and there's a very
real conversation that
we have on camera about how the fact
that the video isn't as good as we
had hoped and like what now to do about
it
and we've gotten a lot better at giving
critiques
and like taking critiques knowing that
it's in the best interest of the video
but
that's really hard but that's a skill
set too it took years to develop that
honestly because there's a lot of times
where
especially as you're you know if you're
i mean you're constantly trying to
improve your your ability yeah right but
but there's also a phase where you
kind of before when you go from amateur
to at least like a consistent
professional
where you're also going through a phase
of of learning how to
take criticism and give criticism but at
the same time
you you yo you're not an amateur
like you know you know your mistakes and
you know
what you should be doing but you're not
quite hitting that
and that's you know you never i don't
think you're ever truly out of that
like as a creator but that is you get
less and less of it ideally over time
but that is one of the hardest things
especially when it first starts hitting
you to really
overcome um because it requires it's
like what
yeah it hurts it's like it requires the
ability to like dust yourself off pick
yourself up
try it again um easy to get defensive
but it's like it's not personal but it's
just like that's the default reaction to
you know criticism is to take something
personally yeah
and you have to like learn to be like
listen me this is not personal
don't take it personally right it's hard
to do yeah yeah
especially here in this kind of stuff it
is it is
quite personal you know because
a lot of personal decisions expression
of your own personality yes but none of
that matters
unless it comes through in the video so
right i mean
you can be as personal as you want but
if you don't let people give you
feedback
and take their feedback then you're
being selfish
and you're not putting out a good video
yeah in fact they're not gonna get
better if you put out a video and no
one's watched it
and you haven't like taken any of their
advice into
consideration if it's untouched by other
people's critiques
don't put out that video it's not ready
yet that's what i'd say
really yeah i mean really yeah like i
think that's
that may be true on the other s at other
end of the rainbow
if you're if you've been creating for
for so long that you know exactly what
you want to do
and it's like you're on the completely
other side of that but that's not what
we're talking about here
that example is yoda yeah we're talking
about anakin
i'm talking like how do i make a good
video with someone who doesn't know how
the lady on the gazebo talking about her
we're it's like
yeah you're okay imagine you're not a
professional comedian
you don't tell jokes for a living you
think you have a very good joke
where do you turn right you turn to
someone you know
someone you meet and tell them the joke
or do you spend four or five
months trying to get an open mic gig
to get on a stage and tell it to like
100 people
for the first time no you wouldn't want
to test it prior
[Laughter]
although that's a good crew video right
there
maybe maybe more of a known one right
now oh my god that is a good
comment where the idea is that we all we
have to write
jokes that we're gonna do for open mic
and then but we we are not allowed
to talk or tell anyone
in the studio wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
wait wait wait like to test out the
jokes
and we cannot no one in the studio can
know like we can you know tell
our families or friends outside of the
studio
but it's an open mic
race oh my god we should do this
i see that desk back there you got some
back there you see that i got some jokes
i got some jokes on that is that a joke
there that's a joke desk
yeah huh it's my joke desk
bills and jokes i'm not going to pay you
the water bill jokes
yeah it's gonna be so it's gonna be so
bad
but so far maybe not how do we redeem
that because we have to
we have to we have to hedge against
utter failure
but if we have to find the comedy i
think that is that is the joke
[Laughter]
i mean some some some people win some
people lose in the comedy game
oh my god let's find out who no no this
is how we do it we edit it together we
super cut
so it's like how did we do and that's a
super cut where we add laughter into
everything
yeah and then and we have a green screen
with the laptop no this is how it
actually went yes and then it's joke and
then followed by like
tons of it's like nathan for you like
awesome
wait wait wait can we just hire people
to come in and be a like studio audience
with no context on who we are
okay that's what we do yeah what if we
what if we do that like
we have we have a stage in the studio
and then we we have like a small crowd
of people that don't know who we are
that come and sit and then in the back
like
one maybe sam maybe you've got like the
controls on like different laugh
keys hold on but here's here's the thing
keep it about this
we keep we have to keep the joke open
like things secret or something
and then there's one person that we
only tell like less than 24 hours in
advance
like let's say peter is here like we go
like peter uh
we need an extra person for a shoot
tomorrow
what is it and we're like uh we need you
to come up with a few jokes
okay like if you just come up with a few
jokes
for everyone uh you know stuff that'll
make people laugh
like how many people it's like oh i
don't know it's just like you know
open mic it's an open it's a pretty
casual open mic casual thing
i think this is a real idea i think we
can totally do this probably next year
probably not this year yeah yeah but we
need you need to have the one person who
has like
no time to think about it and see how
they do
compared to all these people who are
like oh if you really want to like
turn the burner up on that you live
stream the whole thing live on instagram
to our whole audience
so it's like thousands and thousands of
people watching instead of just a couple
dinky real people well then you want to
also release a video
you know what at a time well i mean if
it's part of the video if it's the
conclusion for the video
but yeah i think if it's the conclusion
for the video because you don't want to
ruin the
you don't want to ruin the jokes by
getting them out on live stream early
either way um just throwing it out there
it's a very it's that's pretty very
intense idea
all right well there you go hopefully
peter doesn't watch this podcast
don't watch it peter peter uh yeah
um you should have stopped listening to
this as soon as you heard your name
um so one of them he's not gonna like
dang it peter people are going to send
it to him and now he's going to know
about it okay
maybe we'll title this video what maybe
you want a boss by the way
it could be one of those parentheses
peter don't watch this
i mean it could even be you we might
just call you up and say hey ren
tomorrow at five
dude i really hope the lithium solar guy
watches this video yeah
yeah if you guys um wanna wanna watch
his videos
and let him let him know that you came
from court or cass
that'd be that'd be awesome does anyone
else like what are some of your guys's
what are some good videos you guys have
seen recently
any any any cool wrecks for the audience
all gas no breaks
all the gas no brakes hammers have been
into that one if you guys haven't seen
i'll get a snow breaks
you are i oh yeah yeah i've seen this
guy he is so funny
yeah the portland one is really funny i
watch history
and see what i got for you he's jake
jake you will love all gas snow breaks i
swear
i feel like i know this i don't remember
watch his video titled portland protest
jake
he goes to like crazy places wait i did
see a video where he went to the beach
up in like detroit or something like
yeah
yep okay that was insane it's very dry
super dry
let's see yeah i gotta see that
so good speaking of uh of videos that i
cannot stop watching
uh it's it's
a tragedy but i can't stop watching the
explosion in beirut
oh yeah dude those are crazy videos what
what
what watch the videos you have to watch
the videos that
aren't pointing at the explosion you
have to watch the videos
that are people filming day-to-day stuff
in the city
and seeing what happens those are the
ones
that give you a good context like i was
watching one that was um
they were filming uh it was like a
wedding video of a bride
yeah i saw that filling out nicki out
and and it's just
[ __ ] rains down yeah scary that's where
that
i was like this is cool i'm like whoa
holy crap i mean
granted when i saw 911 i said cool
because i had no idea what the [ __ ] was
going on
yeah whoa that's pretty cool well yeah
it taps on like that
whoa well i like on air and air force
one
i'm yeah i'm thinking this new story
yeah it's like you know
you pass by an accident on the freeway
and you can't look away it's kind of
similar to that you know
yeah never see explosions go off in a
city like this
and so suddenly you have the world's
best reference material for what
something like that would look like
because it is real it's obviously tragic
it's horrific
but it's also incredible in its own
right because it's so just like
this it's pure power of
of energy is is in some of these videos
like
you see like because there's the two
stages or there's like three stages but
after the like the second kind of
semi-big explosion goes off and there's
a huge plume for a couple minutes
some of these videos are so far away and
you're like just like
all the people filming them are you're
like oh they're probably safe where they
are
and then that final explosion goes off
and the camera just gets enveloped
yeah split second you're like there's
that there's a crazy angle
guy was going down the road and you see
the explosion off in the distance and it
like
it eclipses the sun like the whole cloud
that
that is created from it uh literally
condensing the water out of the air
like literally creates a shadow because
it blocks the sun for a moment that's
insane
what was it that exploded so it started
off with fireworks but the fireworks
were stored with a bunch of ammonium
nitrate like almost three
like a thousand tons uh of ammonium
nitrate
and yeah i mean it's fertilizer it's
just because it's a very good oxidizer
and so if you put enough heat in and
what not in it it's
yeah it'll explode we've had the same
sort of accident happen multiple times
throughout history it happened in texas
it happened in canada
it happened in china five years ago yeah
i remember that yeah yeah i was reading
it was like the house 1716
they had like munitions like for world
war one
boat and basically like two boats
crashed into each other
and a fire got started when the
propellers of one boat
tried to like move away post collision
it was like they crash
and they were like wait a second we can
get out of this they start the
propellers up and it created
created sparks which created a fire well
you're going to get out of it
wow one in texas those photos
are insane because like it's like all
wood buildings
and like it's straight leveled like yeah
male effects one was the halifax one was
about twice as big
wow yeah what like the entire town just
disappears
yeah that was uh isn't that what the
isn't that what uh what's his face used
in the oklahoma city bombing
oh uh yeah what's his name yes it was i
think it may have been sodium nitrate i
don't know but it was some sort of
nitrate like that but it used obviously
a much smaller amount
than what we're seeing here right um
yeah so another quick clarification to
the explosion i'm seeing some
misinformation
it was like 2700 tons of ammonium
nitrate there
so people are saying it's like a 2.7
kiloton bomb
but uh the kiloton is referencing tons
of tnt and ammonium nitrate is about 40
as efficient at exploding as tnt so
really it's like
it's it's a little over like a one
kiloton bomb which is still
huge but it's only a fifteenth of what
you know leveled hiroshima
wow
do they know how many people died yet i
think the death toll is up to 150
which is pretty good considering how
just
but it destroyed a lot of buildings and
homes three hundred dollars luckily it
was at the port
i think it's because it was at the port
if it was like in a urban
complex center that would have been yeah
the population density at a port isn't
that high
yeah it's pretty insane too just seeing
these like concrete
structures just turn to powder yeah like
that
yeah uh really uh gives you respect for
the lack of permanence of everything
around us right seeing that stuff you
gotta make the most of it go out and
tell good stories guys
yep i'm sure there's gonna be some
amazing
heroic stories coming out of that that
horrible event
yeah uh
last two videos to put end on a little
bit of a lighter note
somebody put together a compilation of
will ferrell mlb highlights
okay i'll put that in the description
and then um oh i got one what was the
other one
trump interviewing trump oh yeah
uh um
oh uh tom scott's million dollars versus
a billion dollars such a good video
yeah that's a great video if you have an
hour and a half to spare
check it out you don't have to watch the
whole you could skip through it
i didn't watch the whole thing i skipped
through it it was cool that he gave us a
shout out though
yeah it's because i literally saw tom
and we had lunch like
probably like a couple weeks after i'd
finished that video and we had talked
about that sort of thing where he's like
i think it'd be better if he
you do it like linearly in in one
dimension i was like yeah you're right
i didn't do it oops he's like maybe i'll
do it and here we are
a year later and he finally did it yeah
so cool there's tons of great videos
online
everyone who like is able to make a
living off of youtube
probably it makes good videos yeah if
you guys don't know
respect me matt character's got like one
of the biggest
channels on youtube but off the ranch
yup
or demolition ranch um you know
like he's he's just doing like vlog
stuff but even his videos you know
there's still like
he still most of them still have the
fundamental like okay here's my problem
and then here's what i need to do to
overcome that problem
um even though it's you know like vlog
type stuff
um well simplicity can be powerful still
i mean
yeah sometimes you just want to see
someone do a simple task
yeah or experience also unique i think
in the sense that he's not like
he's not some like you know instagram
vlogger
type individual like he's just this this
regular dude that is just kind of out on
his property
and he's just you know that's why he's
got this like ranch vibe nobody's really
doing that
not like that anyway yeah
[Music]
definitely there's this sick uh
documentary that's free on youtube
i'd love to put it down the description
for you guys it's uh kind of like
primtech but
it's documenting this group of people
these
archaeologists technically that are
for the last like 17 years they've been
building a medieval castle from the 13th
century
by hand with only the tools that would
have been disposable back then
and it's freaking sweet dude it's really
insane it's called secrets of the castle
it's a five-part thing on youtube but
wow okay fascinating dude like they've
been working at this like these are
craftsmen they have like the
guy who makes rope the guy who makes the
bricks the guy the master artisan
like stonemason it's it's really cool
and they're all using these like
huge hamster wheel cranes that called
the stones up the towers
it's called uh it's on the channel
called absolute history secrets of the
castle
but it's like an advanced prim tech
basically for anyone who wants to
get into that i'm into that dude you
know what i'm dude
i mean after watching this i was like
how do we
go there and work on a castle for a
month and make contact going
going to england to work still going on
i believe like this is an ongoing like
historical thing in france that they're
doing so it's pretty dope
super fascinating well long story short
there's a bunch of videos out there
guys and uh go out and watch them or go
out and make them so
you're digging up videos that'll
probably be pretty good hopefully
nick and i are going to be filming a
onewheel video next week yeah hopefully
that turns out well that's next week
already
you guys are going yeah it's confirmed
we have our flights we're going we're
gonna get to film
um yeah i'm i'm so excited i have to go
i'm going to go up to the top of uh a
mountain uh when we're down here
are you training every day every day i'm
trying to put in at least like 10 to 15
miles a day
okay park city is it park city
oh we don't know yet top secret we don't
know where the race is going to be held
until like we're there
they are trying so hard to keep a
secretive one so that like
randos don't show up but two to kind of
like create this like reality tv air
mystery you know like the amazing race
you know you show up ready to do
something but you don't know exactly
what you're gonna do
they're gonna let you ride the course
before you race it right that's what i'm
assuming but we also have two days
uh where they're gonna be other
competitions that we're doing and we
don't know what those are gonna be but
right now the main race is gonna be an
off
off-road trail race uh probably through
the woods
it's going to be a course um i'm going
to put a 360 camera on or a gopro
or both i think everyone's going to be
wearing gopros i'm probably going to
bring a 360 camera
usually give like the coolest angles are
you going to cut your hair into a mullet
so okay i've been thinking about doing
something crazy i want to cut my hair
but i don't
want to like mull it just two plugs off
the side
one on each side so like hard buzz on
the side straight
like hard mullet and then just leave
everything else so it's like a mo mallet
yeah yeah yes and then we're like
paint your helmet like an american flag
this is
awful this is absolutely awful that's
horrible
yes dude that's incredible just enough
to distract your opponents
yeah exactly you'll throw them off
they won't even know what hit him yeah
so i'm probably going to try to get my
hair cut
maybe this weekend i don't know how i
might have jenna do it i haven't figured
it out yet
scissors can you guys do you guys can't
get haircuts right now
i don't know can we you can you can
that's illegal that's illegal hey don't
have too big of a party they're going to
turn your water off
well that's another thing son that's
another
videos that's for another time i'll
debate you on that
let's go all right later
i hate parties
is this the outro are we saying goodbye
right now yeah we're saying goodbye
yeah bye everyone thanks for watching
bye that was a fun talk guys yeah it was
good fun
let's do it again sometimes
oh my god